los gobiernos de izquierda de
latinoamérica mantienen la presión sobre
Perú este lunes el presidente de México
Andrés Manuel López Obrador volvió a
insistir en su oferta de asilo para el
presidente de derrocado Pedro Castillo
actualmente en prisión preventiva
mientras la cancillería peruana envió
una carta a su contraparte colombiana el
presidente Gustavo Petro ha estado
cuestionando en sus redes el
encarcelamiento de Castillo las
afirmaciones del presidente Pedro
constituyen una injerencia inaceptable
en los asuntos internos del Perú
especialmente grave en el contexto de
actos de violencia que han ocasionado
lamentables pérdidas de Vidas humanas
una semana después de nombrar gabinete
la nueva presidente Dina boluarte dijo
que iba a reformarlo cambiando el Primer
Ministro Pedro Angulo y asegura que las
protestas están cediendo pero las
imágenes todavía lo desmienten en la
frontera entre Bolivia y Perú hay más de
mil camiones varados estamos esperando
desde el día martes en la noche
cosa que no nos dan paso ya mirar son
cuántos días y ya se nos acaba la
economía los manifestantes han cerrado
el puente internacional que conecta
ambos países
emprendiendo la lucha apoyando a
nuestros hermanos de Lima por tantas
muertes que hubo por el problema que
tenemos por el mismo hecho por haberle
bajaba Castillo la institución de Pedro
Castillo el 7 de diciembre ha desatado
la ira por todo el país en unas
protestas que ya dejan más de 20 muertos
[Aplausos]